there's an absolutely delusional and
insane psychotic article today from
elizabeth spears who's a democratic
digital strategist it's called i was
adopted i know the trauma it can inflict
that's right the left is so addicted to
abortion that now they're going to
pretend that adoption is bad that's how
addicted to abortion they're trying to
remove all other possibilities so no
marriage
no birth control no abstinence before
marriage and now adoption is bad and
creates conflict here is elizabeth's
fears this is just psychotic crap it
truly is psychotic
quote on wednesday as the supreme court
heard oral arguments from state
attorneys seeking to uphold
mississippi's 15-week abortion ban
justice amy coney barrett kept getting
at one question why was abortion
necessary when women who do not want to
be mothers can simply give up their
babies for adoption
again this is an op-ed in the new york
times as an adoptee myself i was floored
by justice barrett's assumption that
adoption is an accessible and desirable
alternative for women who find
themselves unexpectedly pregnant
she may not realize it but what she is
suggesting is that women don't need
access to abortion because they can
simply go do a thing that is infinitely
more difficult expensive dangerous and
potentially traumatic than terminating a
pregnancy during its early stages wait
hold on more difficult dangerous and
potentially traumatic to whom
the entire left-wing position rests on
the complete dehumanization of a
pre-born child that's what it rests on
right oh it's so dehumanizing i mean
here we have an option where the kid
lives and just goes live goes to another
family that wants a baby or we have the
option of you stab it in the face
those are the two choices and you know i
gotta say it's really dehumanizing to
say that maybe the baby should live and
go to another family says elizabeth
spears
and this is she's writing as an adopted
kid
so how did she make that case because if
her mother had made that choice as
ronald reagan used to say
every
the the only pro-choice people who exist
are people whose mothers chose otherwise
right as an adoptive mother herself
justice barrett should have some inkling
of the complexities of adoption and the
toll it can inflict on children as well
as birth mothers but she speaks as if
adoption is some kind of idyllic fairy
tale my own adoption actually was what
many would consider idyllic i was raised
by two adoptive parents alice and terry
from the time i was an infinite infant
and grew up in a home where i knew every
day i was loved a few years ago i found
my biological mother maria and three
siblings i didn't know i had via a dna
test in facebook
the first time i spoke to maria on the
phones has elizabeth spears she lives in
alabama not too far from my parents i
live in brooklyn she apologized
repeatedly for giving me up told me she
loved me and i was i would always be her
family your blood she would say later i
told her and continue to tell her every
time she brings it up the apology is
unnecessary i had a wonderful childhood
i believe she made the right decision
but she remains heartbroken about the
years we missed it together
okay so uh question she remains
heartbroken about the years we missed
together you know what years you missed
together had she chosen to flush you
down a toilet all of them there would be
no years together
and guess what her heartbreak over
giving you up for adoption
that is um that is a that is a side that
is a downside risk to the massive upside
of you being alive to write this op-ed
this is such insane stuff okay so back
to this piece again in the new york
times about a woman who was adopted but
thinks adoption is not the is not the
option when it comes to adoption versus
abortion quote both maria and my mom
alice oppose abortion on religious
grounds my mom is white and southern
baptist maria is hispanic and
pentecostal both like to point to me to
justify their beliefs saying that had
maria gotten an abortion i would not
exist it's a familiar argument the
anti-abortion movement likes to invoke
nobel prize winners who might never have
materialized or potential adoptees who
might have cured cancer if they hadn't
been aborted at eight weeks
i'm no nobel prize winner but i still
resent being used as a political
football by the right i noticed that
you're here to resent it that's the
thing i noticed they're here to resent
being used as a political football
because you're not dead that's what it
was one of the things i noticed i
believe that abortion is a form of
health care and that every woman should
have access to it if she needs it oh do
you
i love these sorts of euphemisms i
believe that more than murder
is a form of cooking
like just fill in the blank with some
random
[Music]
completely bizarre non-sequitur
you know i believe that abortion is a
form of sport i believe that abortion is
a form of art i believe that abortion is
a form of calligraphy like what the
health care for whom not the person
you're killing
perhaps more than that i resent the
suggestion by people like justice
barrett that adoption is a simple
solution i resent it on behalf of maria
who found the choice she made
traumatizing and still feels that pain
44 years later even when an adoption
works out well as it did in my case it
is still fraud wait so let me get this
straight you are alive to resent the
adoption of you
on behalf of your mother
who wanted to give you up for adoption
and is happy she gave you up for
adoption and feels morally morally
blessed that you are alive and that she
didn't murder you
but you resent
that you are alive on behalf of the
mother who was happy to keep you alive
so that you could lead a good life or
you end up as a democratic strategist
pumping out garbage like this for the
new york times
uh honest to god this is like a bizarre
time loop from back to the future too
in which you're alive to complain about
the fact that you are alive
when i echo maria and saying she gave me
up the language always wrangles adoptive
parents because it introduces an
unpleasant complexity
implying that my birth mother was not
completely happy with her choice or
worse that it made her miserable but
that is sometimes the case even when
adoption is the best option for all
involved adoption is not always an
allied good it's a complicated choice in
a situation that has no right or wrong
answer no no i found the wrong answer
it's killing you
that's it was it super hard
i feel like when the options are
woman can keep child and struggle
through the difficulties of raising a
child as say a single mom
or woman can give up child to a
two-parent family that is more
prosperous
and struggle with it with that decision
the choice that's bad is the one where
you just kill the kid that would be the
wrong choice
so you have two choices both of which
have some costs on a personal level and
both of which have some benefits but
both of which have a pretty major upside
which is that you didn't murder the kid
that's like
do you understand the the insane moral
delusions you have to go through to come
to a pro-choice position via this
article and yet this is in the new york
times
if the court overturns roe versus white
says elizabeth spear in the new york
times many women will be forced to give
birth to children they did not want and
did not feel they could afford to
support well you know they they forced
to give the language of force to give
birth to children is so bizarre it's so
weird again
forced to get pregnant is one thing
because typically we call that rape
right if somebody is forced to get
pregnant that is a grave moral sin
forced to give birth is you mean like
your body goes through the process that
normally happens when
you
are when a baby is conceived
you're forced to give birth assumes
that there is
like another natural option there is no
the intervention is the termination of
the pregnancy say
it it's sort of like saying water runs
downhill
okay and um so if you if you take water
and you put the top of a hill and it
goes to the bottom of the hill
and i don't stop that water from running
downhill the water was forced to reach
the bottom of the hill
no if you re-channel the water you're
performing the intervention
there's a massive logical fallacy right
here forced to give birth
nope that's the natural process
just as no one forces you to have a
digestive tract that processes food
you're not like what are we talking
about here
but this does go to the baseline idea
that there's a fundamental underlying
idea which is that biology is force
these folks believe that there is a
spirit in the machine and that any
threat to that spirit of autonomy
is an act of force
and must be defeated
this is what unites the the pro-abortion
movement and the and the transgender
movement is the idea that biology is an
obstacle to your greatest dreams and to
your free-floating autonomy that is
disconnected from your biological
reality
but says elizabeth fears
while pregnant women will undergo the
bonding with a child that happens by
biological design as an embryo develops
into a living breathing conscious human
and then that child will be taken away
wait a sec hoba just hold up i swear
every sentence here is just a gem of
logical fallacy and insanity
so she's arguing against abortion let me
read those sentences again well pregnant
women will undergo the bonding with the
child that happens by biological design
as an embryo develops into a living
breathing conscious human and then that
child will be taken away
um not taken away you're giving it up
for adoption
it's your decision you could keep the
child two you know what takes the child
away also
again i can't overstate this you know
what takes a child away and ends that
that bonding with the child
killing it
pretty good way of of ending that
bonding with a child when i say you make
it sound like adoption is kidnapping
no
but i can tell you know what you what
when's that what ends the biological
design in which the embryo you you bond
with the embryo and the fetus
that would be death that ends that
biological design the right likes to
suggest that abortion is a traumatic
experience for women a last resort a
painful memory but adoption is often
just as traumatic as the right thinks
abortion is if not more so as a woman
has to relinquish not a lump of cells
but a fully formed baby she has lived
with for nine months
again
that's her decision as to whether she
wishes to give the baby up for adoption
but the the complete denial that there
is another character in this story is
the part that's truly going i'm a mother
myself says elizabeth spears to an
adorable six-year-old self-proclaimed
fortnite expert and is often the case i
did not know i was pregnant with him
until the usual symptoms appeared a few
weeks into the pregnancy as anyone who
has just stated a human will tell you
that's a romantic way of talking about
pregnancy just stated a human
there's a vast difference between the
fourth week of pregnancy and the 40th by
the 40th you're familiar with your
baby's regular rhythms of kicking and
moving when i awoke my son would wake up
shortly after i'd feel him turning and
stretching or less pleasantly jamming
his precious little foot into what felt
like my cervix this is one of the
paradoxes of pregnancy something alien
is usurping your body and sapping you of
nutrition and energy by your program to
gleefully enable it and you become
desperately protective of it it's a kind
of biological brainwashing and this hop
often happens whether you want to be a
parent or not right she's just rebelling
against biology she's literally
rebelling against biology my my own
biology is telling me i should love my
child damn you biology saying i should
love my unborn child inside my womb
growing and and learning to love me how
dare you biology this must be stopped by
the way i assume that she's an
abortion-on-demand fanatic which means
that even at the fourth she says there's
a difference between the fourth week and
the 40th week but i assume she doesn't
want any legislation to protect the
child at the 40th week
so um
no
but that that's that's so crazy i'm
sorry it's so crazy to describe
pregnancy as an experience where your
biology
takes over and forces you to love this
this mewling evil leech inside your butt
are there a lot of women who feel this
way about their kids
really i i've yet to meet one
i've yet to meet one who feels that the
child's growing inside of her at week 30
when she feels the baby kicking and she
knows it's a baby that that is a leech
she she she loves it but she wishes she
didn't love it
my god
truly truly despicable stuff justice
barrett says that says elizabeth spears
is well aware of the kind of biological
brainwashing that occurs during
biological brainwashing biological
brainwashing again the natural process
of pregnancy is not biological
brainwashing brainwashing implies force
it implies clockwork orange style i
strap you down to a chair and i force
you to watch propaganda
and that is not what we're talking about
biological brain do you mean the natural
process of childbirth she does
justice barrett is well aware of the
kind of biological brainwashing that
occurs during pregnancy she gave birth
to five children and yet she blithely
seems to assume that a mother can simply
choose not to bond with the child she's
just dating solely on the basis she's
not ready to be a mother or believes she
is unable to provide for the child um
no you assume that because you assume
she can kill it
she assumes the mother will be supported
financially and otherwise throughout the
pregnancy even in a country where
maternal mortality statistics are
abysmal she assumes that children
surrendered for adoption will find a
home and not a pet in the foster care
system no she doesn't assume any of
these things
adoption system should be revamped and
made better um but no
she probably assumes these things
because she cannot fathom being in this
position herself
uh it should be noted that justice
barrett has two adopted children
so um
you're a crazy person
these are assumptions that stem from the
privilege of being financially secure
having never needed an abortion and
perhaps the assumption that women who do
have something that that do have done
something wrong and must face the
consequences
um
well yes i do believe that women who
have abortion have done something
morally wrong yes that is true
i that that's the only part of this
article i agree with in my experience
some on the right believe that the
trauma adoption inflicts is a
consequence of irresponsibility but
unexpected pregnancy is not a de facto
function of bad decision making
um
like 99
it is a function of bad decision making
it can be a failure of contraception
okay in which that's true sometimes
contraceptive fail which is why you
really shouldn't have sex outside of a
context in which you're willing to get
pregnant the product of a rape i know
that's super controversial
it's only controversial
in like the last couple of decades by
the way
like before that all of human history
the notion that you should only have sex
in context in which you are willing to
get pregnant that was a baseline moral
moral motion for literally all of him in
history but now it's very controversial
it can be a failure of contraception the
product of a rape that's literally the
only circumstance that you can talk
about by the way in which
it is legitimate in which pregnancy
literally has no relation to the to the
activity of the woman right is rape
which is why it's the most controversial
aspect of abortion law a mistaken belief
that a woman is infertile there is no
justifiable reason to inflict harm on
women and the babies they might produce
in any of these situations regardless of
judgment wait who's talking about
inflicting harm on babies
you you're talking about why a baby
shouldn't be adopted a baby should be
murdered that is what you are talking
about
the trauma doesn't just affect mothers
either
researchers have a term for what
children who are adopted even as infants
may suffer from later in life
relinquishment trauma
okay i have another term for what babies
may suffer in the womb when they're
killed and it's just called death so if
i have a choice between death and
relinquishment trauma i'm gonna go
relinquishment trauma we'll get to more
of this in a second
i go through this detail to demonstrate
just how far the left is willing to go
this is how far they are willing to go
abortion is so sacred to them it is such
a sacrosanct issue to them that they are
literally willing to say that it is
better for a baby to be
killed in the womb than to be given up
to a happy family for adoption
it's it's wild all righty so just to
complete this article from elizabeth
spears because
the depths of delusion and insanity the
democrats are willing to go in order to
preserve abortion is totally crazy so
there's this article in the new york
times we're talking about in which she
argues that adoption is bad this is how
far they're willing to go in order to
preserve abortion adoption is now bad
it's the worst choice if you have a
choice between adoption and abortion you
should go for abortion according to
elizabeth spears who was adopted herself
quote researchers have a term for what
children who are adopted even as infants
may suffer from later in life
relinquishment trauma the premise is
that babies bond with their mothers in
utero and become familiar with their
behaviors when their first caregiver is
not the biological mother they register
the difference and the stress of it has
lasting effects
see um if you're separated from mommy
you get relinquishment trauma i'm sure
that's true you know what else causes
trauma
i know wait for it wait for it
being stabbed in the head
it's it's a trauma as it turns out being
injected in the heart with poison
little traumatic
being flushed down the toilet these
these seem like
slightly more traumatic things than
relinquishment drama
says elizabeth spear i probably got off
easy in that respect in part because i
did spend a few months with my
biological mother before i was adopted
but that had the unintended effect of
traumatizing my older siblings who
remember me as a baby who was there and
then suddenly was gone this was driven
home to me by my older sister bobby
whose first encounter with me was over
facebook all i can say is i remember you
she wrote and i have loved you and
missed you my entire life
as opposed to if you had been murdered
in which case you guys never would have
met at all what justice barrett and
others are suggesting women do in lieu
of abortion is not a small thing it is
life-changing irrevocable and not to be
taken lightly it often causes trauma
even when things work out it's a
disservice to adoptees and their
families biological and adopted to
pretend otherwise in service or they
need political narrative nope again i
think that the neat political narrative
is that adoption in all of these cases
is better than killing somebody i know
so just to
repeat the left has now said
contraception is not enough you need to
be able to kill a baby in the womb
they've said that sex is not connected
to child bearing which of course is very
silly they've suggested that the actual
imposition is your biological process
taking place
they've suggested that adoption is a
worse option than abortion
all these things are things they are
willing to suggest in pursuit of an end
goal which is that men and women have to
be physically equivalent in every way
which is
unbelievably degrading to women it truly
truly is
if this is the world that you want to
live in with the left then here's the
thing you'll be able to live in this
world after rovers weight is gone all
you have to do is live in new york
all you have to do is live in california
you'll still be able to live in this
delusional crazy world and guess what
you will bear the consequences of living
in that sort of world
at least fewer babies across the country
will have to suffer death at the hands
of people who believe these sorts of
delusional things
the the arguments that the left has been
forced to make in pursuit of their total
their totalitarian
anti-life position
truly astonishing astonishing stuff and
should be humiliating to them if they
had one ounce of humiliation left in
them these are shameful anti-human
arguments these are shameful immoral
arguments that are being made here and
they are taken as perfectly natural and
normal and in fact morally good by the
left i don't know how twisted you have
to be in order to believe that these are
morally good arguments
that these are morally superior
arguments and the people who wish to
preserve human life are the baddies in
this particular scenario
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed